فاللي صار عندنا في السعوديه انه ااه كنا
على الطرف الثاني موقفين عليه معاناه كان
سوق ملخبط اغلبوا مكاتب وتسيطر عليه مكاتب
انا كنت اسميها مكاتب تعقيب جزء كبير منها
همم
يسيطر عليها التستر في شركات جيده ولكن
الشركات الجيده اللي موجوده ما كان مسموح
لها انها تقدم الخدمات النظام يمنعها انها
تقدم الخدمات اللوجسيه همم المتكامل قطع
يتيم ما لها ابوه يعني رحنا لمصلحه
الاحصاء قلنا اضيف النشاط هذا اللي هو
الايسك او او النظام الانشطه التجاريه
نبغى نشاط لوجستي يكون موجود في سجلات
تجاريه يعني وما نقدر روح المرجعكم
تصنيف مال تصنيف ما في نشاط تجاري ههه
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا اعمل
الجريسي استضيف قاعده التحول وقاعده
الاعمال وقاده الراي وسولف معهم على
المستجدات ومستهدفات رؤيه السعوديه 20 30
وهو الاستاذ خالد البواردي
المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تاج لخدمات
البيئه والخدمات اللوجستيه ورئيس اللجنه
الوطنيه للخدمات اللوجستيه حلقه مهمه
لانها تغطي الركيزه الثالثه من ركائز رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 نتائج الرؤيه هي العمق
العربي الاسلامي
محور قارات هو القطاع
تكلمنا عن هذا القطاع من زاويه ابو عبد
الله بصفتهم استثمر في القطار من 2005
وايش كانت البيئه الاستثماريه في السعوديه
قبل الرؤيه واللي على ضوؤها انتقل الى دبي
وبدا اعماله هناك وبعد الاصلاحات
والتغيرات اللي صارت مؤخرا في القطاع رجع
واستثمر في داخل السعوديه فهمنا ايش هو
القطع اللوجستي والشيشمل همم ايش الخدمات
اللي موجوده فيه ايش التشريعات المطلوبه
لنجاحها ويش اهميته همم في اي همم يعني
قطع اعمال على مستوى العالم همم بعدين
تكلمنا على المحاور اللي كان هو عنده مقال
في 2016 يتكلم على ست محاور يجب تطويرها
مثل التخليص الجمركي الموانئ النقل همم
اسعار الاراضي اللي تخص القطاع اللوجستي
جنب الموانئ وغيرها من نقاط مش هنا يعني
التطور اللي صار في هذا النقاط بعضها في
تطور وبعضها لسه ما في تطور تكلمني على
الشركات الناشئه همم اللي تشتغل اليوم في
القطاع ايش الفرس اللي موجوده فيها همم
وين ممكن نقول للشباب الاعمال انتبهوا ترى
هنا في فرص حاولوا تستثروا منها
وبعد ذلك ختمنا الحوار
بان عن رجل على موضوع همم البطاله همم ال
ضيفنا عنده وجهه نظر مختلفه عن وجهه نظر
ضيوف السابقين فاستغرين الفرصه بحيث اننا
نطرح كل وجهات النظر ونجتمع
لاطروحته على موضوع البطاله وليش هو يعتقد
بانها لن تحل بالممارسات اللي تتم اليوم
من خلال وزاره الموارد البشريه والجهات
المعنيه بهذا الملف اترككم مع الحوار حياك
الله ابو عبد الله شرفتنا ونورتنا اهلا
وسهلا حياك الله نور وشكرا على الاصدقاء
الله يحييك ابو عبد الله في موقف او مشهد
همم لاستاذ جامعي نتج عنه قرارين اخذتهم
انت ايام الجامعه
العربيه
اشتغل اعمال حره في الجامعه
الجامعيه في جامعه الملك سعود فكان الدخل
بدا يتحسن او بدا في يصير فيه دخل حتى وصل
الى 12,000 ريال على سنه اولى ثاني في
الجامعه ما شاء الله
فاللي صار
شبه مندوب مبيعات كنت تطلع ما بين
المحاضرات اروح للوزارات والجهات الحكوميه
والشركات واخذ مطبوعاتهم او متطلباتهم
المطبوعات واشوف المطابع اقل الاسعار
فاجيب لهم اقل الاسعار واخذ من المطابع
نسبه 10% ومن الوزاره او من الشركه 10%
كنت ادخل حوالي 20% على كل فاتوره تقريبا
بديت كانت 2000 ريال 3000 ريال حتى وصلت
12000 ريال ما شاء الله ووقتها
دكتور الجامعه
12 الى 14,000 ريال
اللي صار اني دخلت على دكتور في الاداره
الله يذكره بالخير وانا داخل عندك كان
يتكلم بالتلفون يفاصل بنك يبغى سياره
بالتقسيط السياره يعني متواضعه وكان يبغى
يشتريها بالتقسيط
فاذكرني وقفت بره عند الباب وانا افكر كيف
ممكن دكتور يعني اشتغل على نفسه ودرس تسع
سنوات والمكان المرموقه اليوم قاعد يحاول
يشتري سياره بالتقسيط لانه ما يقدر
يشتريها كاش فهنا الصراحه يعني قررت انه
قرارين رئيسي او استمرت معي همم الى وقتها
هذا مع بعض التنازل القرار الاول كان
انه لا يمكن اني اعمل في وظيفه لا في
القطاع الخاص ولا في القطاع الحكومه
القرار الثاني بما انه ما عندي دخل ولا
عندي راس مال فساعمل اي عمل تجاري يدخل
فلوس اهم شيء انه يكون شرعي وقانوني على
نفس هذا السياق ابو عبدالله في كده موجه
لا انا عارفك ما تقدر هذا الشيء بس المهم
علق عليه في موجه لتزييد الناس بالوظيفه
والتقليل منها فتلاقي احد يسميها عبوديه
ولا تلاقي احد يقول اترك وظيفتك وتعال
استمتع بالمال وبعدين اذا يهدون الناس
بطريقه احيانا ما هي حتى اخلاقيه لشخص
مثلا الحمد لله مرتاح
فكيف انت توازن بين اللي قاعد تقول اه
وبين هذه النظاره اللي متطرفه شويه قاعدين
نسمعها من اشخاص يشهدون ناس نظيفه طيب انا
اعتقد انه التجاره عموما هي حق مشروع
للجميع ولكنها لا ما تصلح الجميع هذا واحد
اثنين النجاح مهم للشخص على المستوى
الشخصي في اي يعني كان
سواء في وظيفه حتى لو وظيفه سكرتير انا ما
اتكلم عن وظائف
النجاح والشو النجاح انك توصل لغايهك هل
غايتك انك تكون مبسوط وتطلع ثنتين او
غايتك يكون عندك فلوس على حسب غايتك همم
ممكن اتحقق تحقق او تكون ناجح فانا اعتقد
نعم في مبالغات همم
في بعض الحالات اللي شفتها او من اصدقائي
كان نجاحهم اكبر في الوظيفه اكبر من تجاره
ففي ناس انا اعتقد ما ينفعون الا كادارين
اقوياء بعطيك يعني مثال احد الاصدقاء
كان يعمل في البزنس عشر سنوات ما نجح
اليوم يعتبر من يمكن الاعلى دخولا في
المملكه بعد ما حول الى وظيفه فما نجح في
القطاع الخاص ولكن
في القطاع الخاص
فهي الحقيقه وش اللي يناسبك انت كشخص شو
اللي انت ترتاح له اخوي مره كان في القطاع
الحكومي يحب
يطلعني قلت ما احد يقدر يفيدك الا انت هل
انت تبغى تنتهي من الدوام الساعه 2:00
وتطلع او او
داخل المحدود او انك تبغى تعب ودخل اكثر
وحياه مختلفه همم فانت اللي تقرر ما حد
يقدر يقرر لك فانا نصيحتي انه انت اللي
تقرر نفسك وانت اللي تقرر نفسك
يعني الرحله الجامعيه همم اللي كانت تعمل
فيها برده مبيعات وقاعد تحاول تزيد دخلك
بشكل كده خلاص دخلت على محور همم حلقاتنا
اليوم اللي هي تجربتك في القطاع اللوجستيه
انا اتذكر اول مره سمعت لك ابو عبدالله
خمسه
وش قصه دخولك هذا القطاع
واعتقد بالتزامل معها شرحنا وش القطاع
اللوجستيه طيب والله اذا انت ما تعرف انا
ما اعرفهم يعني
هذا واحد وفي ناس تسال انه كيف انك دخلت
القطاع اللوجيسي وكيف انك بديت في دبي مو
في المملكه
انا طبعا من مواليد الرياض ومن ومن النوع
اللي اغلبه اهل الرياض يطلع اسبوعين ويضيق
صدري ويرجع فما كنت تخيل انه ممكن يوم اني
اعمل لا في وظيفه ولا في بزنس خارج الرياض
والقطع
لكن هي سبحان الله اذا الله كاتب لك الرز
يعني مثل ما يقولون حريم كبار اما يسوق
اهلك ولا يسوق لك انا الحقيقه كانت يعني
توفيق من الله
وكل الصدق سبحان الله ولكن استغليتها يعني
فرص جاءت امامي واستغليتها
البدايه كانت كنت ازور شخص موظف حكومي
وكان عنده واحد امريكي يشتغل في جهه عندهم
مشاريع بالمليرات هذا بعد خروج
اسم الجامعه طبعا طلعت امريكا اخذت
الماجستير
وهذه يمكن فيها درس جميل معلش
لما جيت تخرج من الجامعه كان داخلي وقتها
14 15 الف وتشتغل ثلاثه ايام في الاسبوع
بسيطه
فقال لي خلق ليش ما تروح لامريكا وتاخذ
ماجستير وتتعلم اللغه قلت له ابو سعود انا
اليوم داخلي 14,000 اعلى من دخلك يا دكتور
فكيف تبيني اضحي فيه واروح
فقال اذا دخلك 14 الف اذا رحت لامريكا مو
عشان الماجستير روح لامريكا عشان تاخذ
اللغه بترجع بيكون دخلك 50 و60,000
نصيحه كانت مخاطره بالنسبه لي لكن فعلا
هذه اللي فاتتني فنرجع لموضوعنا كيف
النصيحه هذه اثررت على المستقبل تماما
فلما جلست مع الشخص هذا الامريكي تعرف
الامريكان فرندلي فسواريف وين درس وين رحت
اه فحبيت استغل الفرصه زي العاده فقلت لك
كيف ممكن اني ادخل في عقودكم قبلها طبعا
ما عندنا نشاط انا وقفت اشرطه التجاريه
عشان السفر ورجعت يعني خليت بالعهد توظفت
لسبب يعني كان خالي طلب مني اتوظف عند
الفتره اللي ما وقف على رجولي وبعدين اطلع
من الشركه فسالت الامريكي هذا فقلت له هل
عندكم عقود ممكن انه ادخل فيها فقال ايش
تقدر تسوي قلت كل شيء
او اي شيء فقال هذا موقع عنده موقع كان في
2003 هذا ذكره زي اعتماد
تدخل اللي هم الجهه هذه مازلت تعمل معها
فا بموجب العقود ما اقدر اتكلم ولكنها جهه
عند عقود ملياريه
فقال لي انه عندنا موقع تدخل الدوله
اللي في الوسط هذه ما فهمته
[ضحك]
انا شايل هم اني انسى كلمه بطلع وبروح
ابحث فيها
بشوف همم يعني
هذا ايميل ارسل لي المعلومات وما لك الا
يرضيك
فارسل لي المعلومات بحث لقيت انها اداره
النفايات الصناعيه الخضراء مواد كيميائيه
خطره صعب التعامل معها لابد انك تاخذها
وتتخلص منها بطريقه بيئيه انا طبعا ما
ادري وش المشهد كماله المشهد او كماله
المتطلبات لكن ادري اني اروح اقدر اشيلها
من الموقع الفلاني هم عندهم تجربه سابقه
كانت انه بعض المقاولين كان ياخذها
ويرميها وهذا يضرب البيئه انا ما فكر في
هذه نهائي اضطريت انه طبعا قال وين قال في
الكويت
قال في الكويت
بعد الحصول على الموافقات من وزاره البيئه
في الكويت
نقلنا هاي المستودع معتمد الرجل انبسط على
الشغل المهمه كانت تروح لموقعهم اصنعهم
تاخذ النفايات السامه او صحيح وتخزنها في
المستودع يفترض انك تتخلص منها لاحقا انا
ما اعرف شلون تخلص تخزن
ما عندي مشكله لكن كيف تخلص ما ادري صراحه
بحث طبعا عرفت انه في في محطات معالجه
معينه للهادي ولكنه مو موجوده في دول
الخليج موجوده في اوروبا هنا تطلع دوامه
ثانيه انك كيف تشحنها له اوروبا
فالمقصود ان انا قال لها هو مرتاح هو لانه
كان ممكن يكون عندهم كارثه كانت مخزنه في
الشمس
الشركه الامريكيه اللي كانت مسؤوله عنها
اعتذرت وقالت انا ما ابغى اشتغل في دول
الخليج وجهت صعوبه ما كان في ايميلات وما
كان فيه مواجهه الصعوبات فاطلعت فنقلتها
الرجل انبسط طبعا المستودع كان مرتب وشغل
ومرتب والناقل كان اون تايم يعني كانت
اسمه الوقت كان ترخيص يعني شركه مقاولات
شركه مقاولات شركه مقاولات عندي مؤسسه
فرديه
لكن هم كانوا محتاجين يعني
همم يعني الرجل المناسب في المكان المناسب
ما دقيته اخذناها ولكن كان في اودتين يعني
يطلع يشوف المستودع يشوف الموظفين اللي
جايين كل هذا كان يسوي وانا كنت كلها
مقابله مع بعض
اللي صار انه اعجب فارسل رساله للمكتب
الرئيسي عندهم في المانيا انا بدي افضح
ههه لكن ارسل للمكتب الرئيسي في المانيا
وقال كلمه جميله قال انه خالد اذا وعد
اوفى
فانا انصح انكم تعطونه العقد في دول
الخليج كلها
فاعطوني عقد دول الخليج كلها من ضمنها
الامارات رحت الجبل علي واستاجرت مستودع
ورحت العماره مسقط واستاجرت مستودع
بعدها همم موضوع انه كيف توديها فاكتشفت
انه في طبعا اتفاقيات دوليه للتعامل مع
النفايات الصناعيه الخطره والحمد لله
قدامنا عليها واخذناها وبدينا نصدر
لشركائنا في اوروبا بنينا شركات في اوروبا
ودانا نتخلص منهم طريقه بيئيه سليمه الحمد
لله طبعا بموجب اتفاقيات اسمها باسل اللي
صار غيرنا نموذج العمل عشان اوفر لنا واقل
خطوره بدل ما نجيبها للمستودع
ونشحنها بره نرسل الحاويات المقرئ العميل
ومقر العميل نعبيها له وبعدين نشحنها
مباشره
فكان في مستودعي في دبي 600 م
طبعا جبل علي كانت جميله كانوا يقولوا يا
خالد خذ 10,000 متر بسعر رخيص قيمه
المستودع
وابدا ما احتاج انا مبسوط
لما شفت المستودع صراحه تعامل جمال جبل
عامل لي وهذه نقطه مهمه من ناحيه سهلات
الاعمال يعني جبل عليك انا ويمكن هم من
الاوائل من ناحيه سهوله الاعمال من
الاوائل من ناحيه انه مركز لوجستيه وهذا
بنرجع نتكلم عليه بعدين همم فقلت تدري
خليني اطقطق في ايش اسوي شو اسوي انا عندي
خبره في نقل المواد الكيميائيه صرت خبير
الان ههه يعني
وبعد ما بحثت فعلا
فقلت ادام عندنا خبره في التعامل مع
النفايات الصناعيه الخضراء ليش ما نسوي
خدمات اللوجستيه للمواد الكيميائيه
الخضراء وقت ما كان في المستودع واحد في
دبي
فبدينا جبل علي طبعا قالوا لنا انه ما
تقدر انك تسوي الخدمه كامله
عرض 10000 متر بنينا الحمد لله
ومن هنا في 2005 تقريبا بدات رحلتي مع
اللوجستك للمواد الخطره
والغير خطره الخدمات اللي نقدمها طبعا 3
بي ال اللي هو صرت بارتي لوجسكس او الطرف
الثالث خدمات كامله لوجسيه تحقق من واحد
منها تخليص الجمركي الشحن البحري الجوي
التخزين التوزيع وغيرها رائع جدا في 2005
تاسست شركه تاج الخدمات الاسديه خدمات
خلينا نحط هنا كده استراحه ولا وقفه بسيطه
وقل لنا ايش يعني خدمات لوجستيه
اللي انت جبتها بشكل سريع بس انا ودي اركز
عليها وافهم ايش يعني خدمات طيب ال ال
الخدمات اللوجستيه همم هي فن اداره حركه
البضائع من المصدر الى الاسواق او الى
المستهلك النهائي وتشمل هذه الخدمه او
الاداره النقل البحري الجوي التخليص
الجمركي التوزيع خدمات القيمه المضافه
اللي هي الباكينج الدرامنج وغيرها وبما
فيها طبعا الان همم الميل الاخير طبعا
الخدمات اللوجستيه او القطاع اللوجستيه
المرحله الاولى
انت انت طيب قاعد تنقل النفايات
ايش دخل
ليشتي طيب من هو العميل النهائي
منهم النهائي طيب اللي صار هنا انه فصلنا
ال ال سمينا ال ال الخدمات او النفايات
الخضراء سميناها بمؤسسه تاج للبيئه فصارت
شركه بيئيه همم تقوم باداره النفايات
الصناعيه الخضراء هي شبيهه بنفس اللوجستك
ولكنها خلينا نقول شيء مختص تقريبا يحتاج
خبراء باين موجودين الى محطات معالجه
للنفايات الصناعيه الى اللي يتخلص منها او
محطات المعالجه فهذا بزنس مختلف ودائما
يخلطون الناس لما همم فصار عندنا تاج
للبيئه
مستودع فاضي وقلت انا عندي عقد واحد مع
شركه واحده او جهه واحده بعد اربع سنوات
انتهى العقد العقد اربع سنوات اذا انتهى
العقد طيب انا ايش اسوي ايش اسوي بزنس
فقلت خليني استغل المستودع هذا وابدا في
اللوجسكتي
ومراحل تطور هي الطرف الاول اللي هو الفرس
بي ان ااه بعدين الطرف الثاني الطرف
الثالث الطرف الرابع
الطرف الاول انه المصنع نفسه او المزارع
هو اللي ياخذ بضاعته ويروح يوديها
للمستهلك نهائي
الطرف الثاني انه هو يستعين بطرف ثاني
نقليات اساس انه ياخذ البضاعه هذه ويوديها
همم للمستهلك نهائيا الطرف الثالث لا
دمج مجموعه من الخدمات اللوجستيه مع بعض
بحيث انه ياخذ مني البضاعه يخزنها يوزعها
يوديها الاسواق تعمل لي الخدمات اللوجستيه
اللي يحتاجها كلها وخلاني اركز في شغلي
لذلك الان الطريقه المثلى انك ترفع من
كفاءه القطاعات الاقتصاديه انك يكون عندك
شركات لوجسيه همم
تاخذ الشغل اللوجستي وتخلي الشركات او
القطاعات هذه تتفرغ للنشاطات الرئيسيه
اللي هم يصورنها وتذكر كلمه تقول 90% من
اكبر الشركات الامريكيه او اللي يسمون اس
بي 5
تعتمد في عملها اعتماد رئيس يعني الشركات
اللوجستيه في ال ااه
اشرح لنا قبل ما ندخل في واقع السعوديه في
القطاع اشرح لنا ايش قيمه القطاع اللوجستي
في العالم خصوصا الرؤيه لما بدات او يعني
ثالث ركائزها هو محور ربط القارات
الاعتقدونه
القطاع اللوجستي فوش قيمه هذا الانقطاع
بالنسبه للعالم
طيب الخدمات اللوجستيه طبعا هي البنك
الدولي يسميها العمود الفقري للتجاره
العالميه
المختصين يسمونها شرايين اي اقتصاد يعني
اي منتج تشوفه في البقاله في الصيدليه في
سوق الخضار غير الخدمات اللوجستيه لها دور
كبير فهي تدعم القطاعات الاقتصاديه كلها
همم في امريكا
90% منهم اللي هي اكبر الشركات اكبر 500
شركه امريكيه 90% منهم يعملون كامل
للخدمات اللوجستيه يعملونها الشركات
اللوجستيه لذلك عندهم قطاع همم لوجيسي قوي
شركات همم قويه وايضا هم هذا ساعدهم في
تقليل التكاليف ورفع كفاءه همم اعمالهم
ولو نقول في امريكا مثلا استكمال لها
النقطه في امريكا ايش هي اشهر واكبر واقوى
الشركات في القطاع اللوجستي بس عشان نربط
المشهد للمستمع والمشاهده
تسوي كامل للخدمات اللوجستيه يعني عندك
شركات متخصصه في النقل البحري ام سي مارس
من الشركات هذه عندك شركات عالميه في
الميل الاخير دي اتش ال فيديكس
واقليميه يمكن ارامكس
في شركه مختصه مثلا في همم نقول التخزين
فما في شركه واحده نقول انهم سيطره على
القطاع
احنا يعني خلينا نقول همم مدراء همم
المدير مشروع او مدير القطاع اللوجستي في
في اي قطاع همم احنا دورنا انه نربط
الشركات هذه كلها مع بعض ونقدمها على طب
واحد للعميد بمعنى العميله اليوم همم في
الدول هذه ما يحتاج انه يتعامل مع شركه
تخليص جمركي شركه نقل شركه زي ما هو
متعامل معه في السعوديه في السابق
بل شركه واحده تقدم له الخدمات اللوجستيها
هذه كلها تحت سقف واحد هو مرتاح مجرد يرسل
لك ايميل عندي 1000 حاويه دبرها عمرك
انتهيت الشرطه
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدرتنا لنمكن نبتكر في تبني
احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه وذكاء
سالوشي سبايسي
[موسيقى]
فينك مقاله في 2016 تقول فيها اكبر
المشكلات التي يعانيها القطاع الاجتماعي
في المملكه هي اجراءات التخليص الجمركي
متوسط عدد ايام تخليص الحاويه 9 ايام في
دبي يومين المشكله الثانيه عدم توافر قطار
لنقل البضائع بين ميناء جده وميناء الدمام
والميناء الجاف في الرياض المشكله الثالثه
تطوير الموانئ والسرعه التنزيل والتحميل
للسفن وزياده عمق المياه المشكله الرابعه
عدم وجود مناطق حره لاعاده التصدير
المشكله الخامسه عدم توفر اراضي ومناطق
لوجيه مخصصه جنب الموالع المشكله السادسه
النظام لا يسمح بانشاء شركات خدمات تجسسيه
تقدم الخدمات الجنسيه كامله للعميل هذه
كانت مشاكل 2016 في مقالات 2016
هذا قبل رؤيا وبعدها
يا رب انها المشاكل خف منها شيء والله
غلبها خف بس انا ما ادري وين جبت تقريبا
اللي صار انه احنا المملكه
توقفت عند توبيل مو احنا قلنا الطرف الاول
للطرف الثاني احنا توقفنا عند الطرف
الثاني لمده يعني ال 40 سنه الماضيه ما
تطورنا عن الطرف الثاني الناس المتقدمين
اللوجسين وسلطه طبعا
احنا همم وقفنا عند الطرف الثاني الثاني
يعني انه القطاع كله كامل او جميع لقطاعات
الاقتصاديه اذا تحتاج خدمات لوجستيه تضطر
انها تتعامل معه وخلص جمركي ناقل شاحن
تتعامل مع اربع خمس جهات وتضطر انها يكون
عندها مستودعاتها ويكون عندها فريق ومعدات
همم للمناوله همم
فهذا كان المشهد وكان فيه طبعا تكاليف
اضافيه وما زالت الى اليوم يعني تكاليف
اضافيه كبيره لا على الاقتصاد ولا على
القطاعات بمعنى انت اليوم اذا بتسوي
الطريقه هذه 2 بي ال معناها اذا عندك
50,000 شركه تحتاج الى 50 بتحتاج الى عشر
عمال في شركه عشان المستودع حقها تحتاج
مستودع هذا بيضاف
للمركز المالي حقها او ميزانيتها ففي
التكاليف استثماريه
وبتحتاج معدات فهذا بيرفع تكاليف
التشغيليه وبيرفع عندها عدد العماله اللي
هي محتاجهتها
الدول المتقدمه لا هذه كلها ما هي موجوده
عندهم فشف كم متوفر انت اذا طورت القطاع
معنى اخر شركه لوجستيه تقدر تختم لها 50
مصدر او 500 مصر فبالتالي مستودع واحد عشر
عمال وفروا عليك هنا تقريبا حوالي 1000
عامل او 50 مليون قيمه المستودعات
فانت كده ترفع كفاءه الشركات هذه او
القطاعات هذه وبالتالي ترفع من كفاءه
الاقتصاد بالكامل فالي صار عندنا في
السعوديه انه كنا على الطرف الثاني
وموقفين عليه معاناه كان سوق ملخبط اغلب
ومكاتب وتسيطر عليه مكاتب انا كنت اسميها
مكاتب تعقيب جزء كبير منها
يسيطر عليها التستر في شركات جيده ولكن
الشركات الجيده اللي موجوده ما كان مسموح
لها انها تقدم الخدمات النظام يمنعها انها
تقدم الخدمات اللوجسيه همم المتكامل
كده
لازم تسوي اربع شركات عشان تلقى بعضهم
النقل باسمه مثلا والتخليص الجمرك باسم
همم يعني او تخليص الجمرك باسمه والنقل
باسم زوجته
كل الامكانيات اني اخدم عميل بما فيها
الاستيراد فانا اذا باستورد لازم تصريح
اتجاري هو يقول لا ما تصير انت تستورد
بضاعه وتخلص
يا جماعه العالم همم
اللي صار المشهد كان ملخبط ما كان في
قطاع قادر على انه ينمو ويوظف ما كانت في
كيانات كبيره
تنمو ممكن انها تخلق وظائف للسعوديه فكان
مسيطر عليها صراحه العماله الاجنبيه همم
بعد الرؤيه انا اعتقد مو اعتقد انا انا
اجزم انه ال ال اللوجستك او الخدمات
اللوجستيه الحديثه هي ولادتها مع اعلان
الرؤيه بمعنى انه تمكن القطاع الخاص انه
يسوي الخدمات اللوجستيه هذه لانه هدف
المملكه اليوم انك تصير مركز لوجستيه
عالمي ما تقدر تصير مركز لوجستي عالمي
بدون ما تمكن
القطعه الاقتصادي او الشركات او القطاع او
شركه اللوجستيه ونذكر لما كنت همم بس اضيف
معالي الدكتور ربيع
اللي كان مسؤول عن هيئه النقل والان هو
نائب وزير النقل شاورتك وقتها قلت لك
بقابله محمد ايش في سؤال في بالك قلت اللي
اساله
ليش حنا ايتام مال ابو
القطاع اللوجستي انت كنت تصرفه باللي يتيم
ليش
ابو محمد الله يمسيك بالخير معاي دكتور
رميح رئيسنا الان في مجلس الشركه اللوجستي
فانت الحين يعني بيفصلني
ففعلا هو كان اهم التحديات انا اعتقد كان
في مشكلتين كبيره في القطاع اللوجستي
خصوصا لما اجيت
وتوليت
اللجنه الوطنيه اللوجستيه يعني معالي
الدكتور صراحه من القيادات اللي يدعمنا
كثير في القطاعتين اول ما جينا
شفنا وش المشكله كانت اول مشكله انه ما في
قطاع خاص يمثل القطعه اللوجستي بشكل صحيح
فالحكومه لما اجت في الرؤيا قالت يا جماعه
انا مالي في القطاع انا حكومه في الاخير
احتاج قطاع خاص اتفاهم معاه يكون الذراع
الايمن عشان نحقق هدف الرؤيه في جعل
المملكه مركز لوجيسي فكان اول تحدي
انه كيف نجمع شتات هالقطار يعني بس ارجع
للنقطه انه كان 2 بي ال انه القطاع مفكك
هذا انعكس على الغرفه التجاريه صار الغرف
التجاريه في لجنه فرعيه تخليص جمرك لجنه
للنقل لجنه للشحن البحري فكان كل واحد في
لجنه مختلفه فاحنا اول ما جينا قلنا لا بد
ان ننظم انفسنا كقطاع خاص يمثل القطاع
فسوينا لجنه اللوجستيه وكانت اول لجنه تضم
جميع الانشطه اللوجستيه تحت سقف واحد
الميل الاخير تخليص الجمركي الشحن البحري
الشحن الجوي
[موسيقى]
لادهبال والسيرفس فكلها جمعناها في لجنه
واحده وتشرفت برئاستها همم الفتره هذه
بعدها قلنا وين المشكله الثانيه وجدنا انه
المشكله الثانيه انه القطاع يتيم ما لقاه
يعني رحنا لمصلحه الاحصاء قلنا اضيفه
النشاط هذا اللي هو الايسك او او النظام
الانشطه التجاريه نبغى نشاط لوجستي يكون
موجود في سجلات تجاريه يعني وما نقدر نروح
نرجعكم
ما في نشاط تجاري
محترف فيك
يعني تيجي تقول قطاع اللوجستي اتذكر احد
الجهات ولا ابغاذكرها
كلموني قالوا عندنا تعليمات انه ندعم
القطار
اللوجستي هو ايش رايك انت كخبير اعطينا
رايك قلت شو تعريف القطاع اللوجستي قال ما
ادري
هل تروح تدعم النقليات لحالها هل تروح
تدعم الويرها
فكان في مشكله ما كان في تعريف ما كان في
مرجعيه كنا فعلا ايتام كانت 19 جهه
يعني يعني لها دخل بالقطاع اللوجستي اااه
قلنا افضل شيء واول شيء من ناحيه
استراتيجيه اتركوا عنا المشاكل التشغيليه
خلونا نتكلم عن المشاكل الاستراتيجيه انه
يكون عندنا مرجعيه عشان نطور القطاع نحنا
نشتغل نحن وين نطور القطع وهذا اللي صار
الحقيقه يعني جزاها الخير مع الدكتور
ومعالي الدكتور ماجد القصبي كلهم صراحه
كانوا يعني متفاهم
اصبح انشات وكاله خدمات اللوجستيه حتى
اسمه الوزاره تغير حتى اسم الوزاره تغير
وهذا يعني شيء صراحه همم وايضا انه همم
والاجمل من هذا كله ايضا همم وضع همم اللي
هو
الرخصه اللوجستيه الموحده لتاهل كشركه انك
تاخذ رخصه وحدات اهلك انك تقدم جميع
الخدمات اللوجستيه تحت الصفر اليوم موجوده
هذه 3 بي ال اليوم نعم والرخصه موجوده
اخذتها تقريبا من حوالي 35 شركه وكلنا
واحده من الشركات اللي اخذتها فهي موجوده
اليوم همم الان تحت التجارب والتفعيل لكنه
موجوده واي شخص ممكن يقدم عليه لو برجع
للنقاط السته اللي انت تكلمت عنها يعني
هذا صراحه تطور كبير على مستوى مرجعيه
القطاع والجهه المشرفه عليه بس خلينا
ناخذهم واحده واحده التخليص الجمركي وايش
اللي اختلف فيه هل مازلنا على التسع ايام
شوف التخليص الجمركي همم
مو بس كانت مشكله التسعيان تخليص الجمركي
اذا انت تبغى تسوي ترخيص جمركي او ترخيص
جمركيه من شروطه ان يكون معك ثانوي
من شروطه انه لازم
اعتقد كان في شرطين يا انك تكون اكس جمارك
يا ان يكون معك شهاده
الثاني كانوا انه انت يا صاحب الحلال تيجي
تاخذ عنده دوره جمركيه كيف تدخل البيانات
الجمركيه
فاول لقاء مع معالي رئيس الجمارك الله
يذكره بالخير ابو عبد العزيز
الحقباني انه الجماعه يعني كلها اون لاين
هذه تصير ليش انا كصاحب شريكه اجي اخذ
دوره ارسل موظف عندي اخر دوره احنا البلد
الوحيد او او من الدول اللي همم ودي اتش
ال ما عنده يعني تخيل الشركات هذه ما يحق
لها انها تسوي ترخيص جمرك فبالتالي تعتمد
على مكاتب هذه قد تكون جيده وقد ما تكون
جيده همم
فكانت هذه المشكله نيجي للمشاكل الثانيه
فكانت الحاويه تاخد قطن 15 يوم نزلوها الى
90 في دبي 24 ساعه التطور الكبير صراحه
والجميل اللي صار صارت تخلص في ساعتين
الان
بعد اذا انت انت
عشتها تجربه
الى الان الخدمه هذه ما نفعل نفسها في
السعوديه احنا فعلا لكن
اللي معي اعضاء اللجنه كلهم جربينها اذا
قدمت اوراقك كامله ممكن انها تخلص في
ساعتين الى ثلاث ساعات
فيه عدم توافر قطار لنقل البضائع هذه
واضحه ومصر قطر الشغالين عليها انا
اعتقدوا فيه الربط والهادي ولكن هم مهم
مثل اهميه الموانئ الموانئ صار فيها تطور
كبير وايش صار في الموارد هذه النقطه
الثالثه تطوير الموانئ وسرعه التنزيل
والتحميل وزياده عنق المياه والله يشوف
الموانئ انا ما ودي اتكلم عليهم واحرق لكن
عندهم همم نجاحات كبيره انا اعتقد بس سمعت
امس همم كلام همم لاحد المسؤولين جميل انه
ارفعه وانا اعتقد همم من الكميه
الترانسبنت او الشحنات ترانزيت من الثمن
من 18%16 الى 23%
في نجاحات كبيره صراحه ما اعلم يعني ما
ودي اني احرقها عليهم همم
حاولنا والله ما وافقوا
بهديه يعني هسه ان شاء الله ان اتذكر انا
من الاشياء اللي نشرناها في برنامج واحد
في في رمضان الماضي انه همم دكتور ماجد
القصبي يقول كان
المسافر او ترانزيت البضائع ممنوع النظام
ممنوع انك انت تجيب بضاعه تنزلها في
السعوديه تم تعيد تصديرها الاماكن الاخرى
بكل ما في ذلك من الفوائد اقتصاديه
مستودعات همم تزود بالوقود كل هذا الاشياء
كانت همم ضائعه لانه هذا كامل ممنوع الان
اعتقد الي صار مسموح وبدات تشتغل اكثر من
رحله همم
الموضوع همم
الرابعه هي موضوع مناطق حره لاعاده
التصدير ليش هذه مهمه
هذه مهمه انك تجيب
الشركات الاجنبيه ويكون البلد كهب بمعنى
انه يدخل بضاعته وما يحتاج انه يدفع عليه
جمارك فيخليها وهذا اللي صاير مثلا في في
جبل علي فتجد انه جبل علي اذا ماني غلطان
60% من بضاعه تسجيل السعوديه تخيل
الامارات هي الشريك الثالث اكبر شريك
اقتصادي للمملكه يعني بعد امريكا والصين
السبب اللي هو ريكس سبورت
المملكه
على البحر الاحمر ومنه في الخليج العربي
همم فليش ما بضاعتنا تيجي عندنا واحنا
نخلصهم واحنا هنا طبعا تصير الفائده همم
فائده
دخل الغير نفطي فائده تطوير القطاع
اللوجستي وايضا تمكينه فالبلد بيستفيد
منها وبنكون حنا هبل
ما فيها جمارك او ما فيها رسوم الدوله
الخدمات الجمركيه ما اللي عندك خدمات
ورسوم لازم تدفعها النقل الوظائف اللي
بتكون في يعني جبل عليه اعتقد في 4,000
شركه بتخيل انه 4,000 او 10,000 شركه احنا
نعتبر قاره همم تخيل لانه كم عدد الشركات
اللي ممكن تيجي اذا عندك الفريزون واعتقد
انه يعملون عليها واحتمال
اعتقد انه في يعني من وصل ما تاخر اعتقد
انه في في اخبار ان شاء الله جميله غريبه
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله عنها
في برده الموضوع عدل متوفر اراضي
ومناطقسيه همم مخصصه للشركات باسعار
منطقيه في المؤنثه هل بدك تخصصه لكم هذا
ههه
شوف احنا القطاع شوف هدف الرؤيه لا يمكن
ان تصلها الحكومه الوحده هدف الرؤيا في
جعل المملكه مركز لوجستي عالمي لا يمكن ان
تصل المملكه او الحكومه لحالها ولا يمكن
ان يصل الانقط خاصه الحاله فلا بد انهم
يروحون سواء عشان لانه من ضمن مؤشرات
الخدمات اللوجستيه ومؤشر البنك الدولي
للخدمات اللوجستيه موثوقيه القطاع الخاص
عندك في القطعه اللوجستي فلا بد منهم
يروحون سواء في فيها السباق للوصول للهاتف
اذا انك توصل
لابد انك تطور القطاع
او الشركات اللوجستيه وليس فقط القطع
اللوجستيه القطاع اللوجستي تطورها انك
طبعا بالانظمه التشريعات والان يعني
اشتغلوا عليها ما شاء الله وتحسنت ولكن
نفس القطعه انت قطاع اتكلم عن شركات لهم
40 سنه وهم يقدمون خدمات
اذا بتفتح الحبل على الغارب وبتجيهم شركات
تسريب
وعندها خبره اكبر
وميزانيه اكبر ودعم اكبر فقد تضر بالشركات
هذه فلا بد انك تمكن الشركات هذه وتطورها
بحيث انها تكون كفاءتها عاليه تخدم توصل
اييي لهدف الرؤيه في جعل المملكه مركز
من اهم الممكنات خصوصا لخدمات التري بي ال
والادباري اللي هي الاراضي اللوجستي
ليش احنا نقول باسعار منطقيه لانه القطاع
عموما كبش ماركه
يعني مقارنه معياريه واي كمعيار عالمي
الهامش الربح في قليل يعني تكلم عن عشره
او 12%
وايضا هو اللي يرفع ويقلل التكاليف على
جميع القطاعات فلا بد تكون تكاليف قليله
لانه عشان يربح وفي الاخير يخدمك همم
مهم جدا صراحه انه همم مو بس الهدف
الاقتصادي او احنا نقول لهم دائما لما
نيجي معي الجهات الحكوميه اللي عندها راضي
يقول لها ابغى ارفع السعر
نقول يا جماعه في
في ارباح غير مباشره على الاقتصاد اكثر من
الخمسه مليون ولا العشره مليون اللي انت
تطمح لها في في يعني جبل عالي وش اللي
خلاني ابدع عنده اللي خلاني ابدا انه
الارض كانت ولا شيء
الارض العشره الاف متر كانت قيمتها
120,000
فكان الوضع مغري جدا يعني عندك ارض ب
120,000 وعندك مين في السنه 120,000 درهم
في السنه
وعندك ميناء كان قاعد يجيب لك 6 مليون
بالنسبه يمكن 15 20
نعم
يقطع الشارع عندك سوق
انظف الى ذلك الى السهوله الاعمال
طبعا رفعوا الاسعار بعدين لكن متى ارتفعت
الاسعار لما وصلت الميناء في جبل علي 14
مليون رفعوا الاسعار الى 25 30 35 60 يمكن
اذا انت على شارع الشيخ زايد ولو حتى
فاحنا نقول اليوم الجماعه يعني سددوا
وقاربوا نبغى اراضي لوجستيه هم شغالين على
كذا منطقه
السعر فعلا يعني موضوع ساخن واحنا واياهم
همم يعني سمعت عن منطقه ال ال الخمره
هذه تعتبر المنطقه الجنسيه اذا انت صرحتها
منطقه اللوجستيه لانها قريبه
فيها اراضي
للقطاع الخاص
وهيئه المدن والجبال عندهم همم
عنده مساحه كبيره وقريبه من الموانئ
ما بدي فيها شيء لكن في مشكله ثانيه بعضهم
يقول لك يعني يروح خذ في في مناطق يعني
همم بي ما تقدر اذا انت شركه لوجستيه لازم
تكون عند وقريب من الموانئ الجبيل الان
عندهم تجربه جميله
بس انه سعره غالي ولا حتى ما في لا لا فيه
فيه كم سعر المتر عشان قارن والله شفت
اراضي همم حاليا يعني اقرب شيء ممكن اقول
لك واا قليله سعر المتر يكون 40 الى 50
ريال
فمستودع يوصل همم 120 الى 150 120 ريال
120 كمستوى مقاطع 18 ريال لا همم 40
مقارنه ب 12 40 بس تتكلم هناك عن موضوع
مختلف سوق مختلف يعني المينا جنبك همم
يعني راضي يرخص وسوق اكبر تقريبا اذا تكلم
عن القطاع او في الميناء نعم
[موسيقى]
فيها يعني اليوم حراك في رياده الاعمال
جدا ايجابي قاعدين نعيشه في السعوديه
ولانه مسمى القطاع اللوجستي جديد علينا
فيمكن نجرب القطاع للناس لما يضرب امثله
لشركات ناشئه
تصنيف من هذا القطاع ايش في شركات اليوم
رياده اعمال تعتبر قطاع اللوجستي
شوف القطعه اللوجستي طبعا كثير يجيني من
شباب الاعمال يقول انا خدمات اللوجستيه
طيب ايش تبغى تبدا فيها ما ادري ابغى
خدمات اللوجستيه فاقول لك انت غير جاهز
سووا واجب بعدين تعال اسال يعني ممكن انك
تصير شركه شحن بابا فقط ممكن انك تصير ميل
اخير له توصيل الشحنات ممكن انك تصير
تخليص جمرك طبعا في في نقاش حول انك اذا
انت ناقل فقط ولا توصيل من الاخر هل انت
لوجستي ولا لا يعني الماني هم المركز
الاول في مؤشر الخدمات اللوجستيه
وسالناهم همم من تعطون اللقب هذا اللي هو
لوجستك او خدمات لوجستيه قالوا نعطيه للي
عنده اكثر من الخدمه
يعني اذا ناقل ما نعطيه
اي شركه عمر للنقل ما اسميك شركه عمر
اللوجستيه لازم اسوي الخدمتين في اكثر
لازم تسوي خدمتين في اكثر وهذا نرجع
لتعريف القطاع اللوجستي ايضا هو انت قريشن
او الدمج ما بين الخدمات هذه وليس فقط انك
تسوي خدمه واحده هو فن اداره
الجنسيه
واعتقد عندهم توصيل فاذا عندك اكثر من
خدمه نعم هم فلفل من سنتر واعتقد عندهم
توصيل همم فعندك ثلاثه احد الامثله جميله
همم مثل ما قالت المشارع
لوجستيه الناجحه همم ايضا في شركات كثير
الصراحه التوصيل النيل للاخير الان كثيره
ما يحظرني اسمائهم لكن في اسماء كثيره
يزعلون علي طبعا هو ينقل بضاعه ينقل بضاعه
لكن ما فيه دمج او قريش يعني ما تقول
تخزين اذا بناخذ بالمصطلح الالماني هو
شركه غير لوجستيه وشركه توصيل اطعمه
المفهوم الجديد اليوم حق الدارك ستور او
المتاجر
عربيه اللي هي ممم
يعني
المتاجر الظل يمكن يمكن
فقط تستخدم
للاشخاص المستفيدين او المستخدم نهائي هل
تعتبر الخدمات الجنسيه هي هي تعتبر بس ال
ال الخدمات اللوجستيه في الغالب اييه
الناس منظور الناس لها والقطاع لها انها
البضائع اللي تيجي بالبحر بضائع كميه
كبيره وليست
يعني انك وصل وصل لبن وصل يعني الميل
الاخير قد يندرج الميل الاخير اذا تكلم عن
الشحنات او توصيل الطرود هذا طبعا قد
يندرج تحت الهادي نعم المسمى واسع يعني ما
ما فيها حتى جاهز ممكن يطلق عليها انا ما
ابغى همم
ابو عبد الله انت ما شاء الله همم فتره
طويله تابع في تويتر دائما عندك حرص على
طرح فراس هذه فرصه كده لو اخذنا قطع
اللوجست اليوم وفي احد يسمعنا عند الحماس
والرغبه انه يبدا نشاط هو هيسوي الهوم ورك
وهو مسؤول يبحث يطلع ويجيب الاستثمار
والدراسه هذه المسؤوليه بس
كان منطقه تقول يا جماعه الخير انتبهوا
ترى هنا في رزق هنا في هوامش ربح حلوه ولا
حد قاعد يشتغل فيها وايش المنطقه اللي لسه
لم تخدم فيها فرص حلوه ضمن انقطاع
اللوجستي
مش القطاع اللوجستي مثل ما قلت لك انا
اعتقد في السوق في السعوديه اقطع بكر
مازلنا الى اليوم رغم التطورات اللي
قلناها مازلنا الى اليوم في في بدايتنا في
في بدايه الرحله اللوجستيه انا نقول دائما
همم انه اول شيء لازم نفتح عيون الناس انه
في عندهم خيار سواء على الوظيفه نرجع
لموضوع الوظيفه التجاره نجيء اذا قرروا
بحيث انه يختار مو بنت اللي اختار مو بنت
اللي توجه تقول له روح الوظيفه او روح هذا
خيارك انك همم نفس الموضوع اللي يتكلم فيه
الشيء الثاني بالنسبه لوجستك همم ايضا انا
دائما اقول في المشاريع اما اصنع شيء جديد
او طور شيء قائد فلابد انك تختار عندك
الشحن البحري طبعا قد يكون عندك وكيل شحن
بالعموله عندك توصيل عندك
منافس لنا همم عندك هذه ايضا فيها سوق
كبير
عندك النقل النقليات الان خصوصا مع الجهود
على القضاء على التستر ايضا في دمان دعالي
او في طلب عالي عليها فكلها فيها خير
صراحه لكن دائما الارباح في انك تسوي شيء
مميز بمعنى انا لما جيت في دبي وسوينا
المواد الكيميائيه الخدمات اللوجستيه
المواد الكيميائيه ما كان فيه الا شركه
واحده
ولكن عشان اصدقهم القول عشان ما يروحوا
يسوون زي انه اليوم اللي افتتحنا فيه
احترقت بالكامل
يعني ابد اليوم اللي
افتتحنا فيه احترقت بالكامل فحتهم
الى الان والله الى الان اتذكرها انه همم
فاتح الشباك الصباح قايم بروح الجبل عالي
عشان الافتتاح
وشوف دخان اسود مخيف
ما زال موجود في الاخبار اعتقد انه كان
على 2005 2006 شيء مخيف فهل اروح ولا ما
اروح شو القصه اسال اسال يا جماعه مش
القصه قالوا الشركه الفلانيه وهي الشركه
الوحيده احترقت مشكله المواد الكيميائيه
المشكله
بمعنى ممكن تحط مادتين يتفاعلون مع بعض
هذه تتبخر وهذه تستقبل البخاري
وغيرها ولكن
ارجع الموضوع لما دخلنا القطاع هذا كنا
احنا الوحيدين حتى جبل علي لما يجون يعطوه
برزنتيشن انه يذكرون تاج وجلسنا فتره احنا
الشركه الوحيده الموضوع مخيف صراحه يعني
اصبحت كلمه قالوا فتره الصيف في حريق في
جبل علي اقوم
فالمقصد انه تميز ادخل في نشاط ما في ناس
كثيرين يحتاج اليوم الناس كلها معها فلوس
والا ما معه فلوس عندها اكسس انه يجيب
مستثمرين خصوصا مع هبه الاستثمار الجديد
همم الفلوس ما هي مشكله انك تختار فعلا
القطاع يا انك تطوره يا انك تختار قطاع ما
احد دخل فيه اخيرا يمكن عندي مشروع جديد
همم
وهو يمكن اللي انا مؤمن فيه ما ودي اخليهم
ينافسوني ولكن التقنيه في القطاع
كيف تستخدم التقنيه في القطاع اللوجستي
هذا انا اعتقد انه شيء مهمم اذا بتتميز في
شيء اساطير اداره مخزون والشهاده الان
اداره الميل الاخير يعني شفت صديق سوي
لوكيشن اللي كل شويه مكلف حلينا المشكله
هذه تماما مشكله العنوان ايضا حليناها همم
مشكله انه يعطيك
نافذه يقول لك انا بجيك من زمان الصبح الى
خمس في الليل همم ايضا حلينا هذه كلها انت
تستطيع بتقنيات او بحلول
تطبيق تطبيق
هذا يرفع تقريبا من كفاءه التفصيل حوالي
20%
ويوفر على القطاع الصراحه لا من الناحيه
بيئيه ولا من ناحيه التاليه
ويكفيك انه لا انا وياك في مقابل الان
بيدق خمس كول صديق سوي له لوكيشن اعطيني
الموقع فانا اعتقد انه نصيحتي للشباب
القطعه كلها سواء لوجسي او غيرها يا انك
اخلق شيء جديد او ادخل شيء في مميز همم او
انك تطور شيء قائم وسووا طريقه مختلفه في
برنامج ادلب برنامج
الصناعه والخدمات اللوجستيه عندهم كثير
مبادرات ما ما راح ادخلك فيها لانه عندنا
حلقه سابقه همم
مدير البرنامج بس من الموبايلات الملفه
بالنسبه لي تحسين التشريعات المتعلقه
بخدمات اللوجستيه التواصل مع القطاع الخاص
داخليا وخارجيا تطوير راس المال البشري في
مجال خدمات اللوجستيه في هذه الثلاث محاور
محور التشريعات محور التواصل القطاع الخاص
ومحور راس مال البشري وش الشيء اللي تحس
انهم مبدع فيه ايش الشيء تحس انه لسه
نتمنى واحد اثنين ثلاثه
انا اعتقد
والله في اشياء كثيره يعني انجزوها من
اهمها بالنسبه للكوادر البشريه انشاء
الاكاديمي الاكاديميه اللوجستيك هذه طبعا
بدت نعم وخرجت خرجت اول دفعه اظن او ثاني
دفعه وعليها طلب كبير يقودها ام علي دكتور
رميح الرميح يعني ما انك ذكرت اسمه وهو
صراحه من الناس اللي كانوا ساهم في
تاسيسها او كانت نتاج للتعامل ما بين
القطاع الخاص والقطاع الحكومي ومن ضمن
طبعا همم
هذا اول شيء وانا اعتقد انه اهم شيء لانه
فعلا القطاع اللوجستي كان يحتاج همم كوادر
بشريه سعوديه والان والان همم هذه
بالنسبه
للدعم يمكن عندهم دعم المشاريع الصغيره في
برنامج الالف ميل اعتقد انه توهم بادينا
على اساس يدمعوا يدعمون همم المشاريع
اللوجستيه والصناعيه الصغيره فهذا مهم اا
المناطق اللوجستيه هي اللي مازالت متاخره
الصراحه ما زالت متاخره وانا اعتقد هي قلب
همم
لا تستطيع انك
تفاعل وكلها الحراك هي ها المنصه لكن
المنصات موجوده لكن كم سعرها هنا هو
المحكم انت سعرها بحيث ان تصير اسعار
منطقيه تشجع القطاع الخاص ولا تعطيها اي
احد احنا ما بنقول اعطها يعني على قولهم
غدا مجاني احنا نقول اذا في قيمه مضافه من
هذه الشركه وهذا القطع للاقتصاد من الافضل
انك انك تعطيهم واسعار رخيصه يعني بعطيك
مثال كان فيه قبل فتره مع مع التضخم
شكاوي على ارتفاع الاسعار جزء كبير من
ارتفاع الاسعار هو ارتفاع الخدمات
اللوجستيه لا في الميل الاخير لا في الميل
الاول ولا في الميل الاوسط ولا في الميل
الاخير
البنك الدولي ايضا للتقرير وهذا عن اهميه
القطاع اللوجستيه مثل ما قلنا انه العمود
الفقري للتجاره العالميه
يقول لك
كلمه يعني لا تستطيع انك تنافس عالميه او
حتى اقليميا وانت ما عندك خدمات لوجستيه
متطوره فالخدمات اللوجستيه متطوره هذه
بتخليك منافس لمن ناحيه الصناعه لا من
ناحيه الخدمات لا من ناحيه تحدث فهي صراحه
هي فعلا العمود الفقري
للاقتصاديات وفي التشريحات وايش التشريع
اللي تنتظره
لكننا ننتظره انه رفع المنع عن شو اسمه
على مثل
وبالعكس الان انا اعتقد انه
اللي بيصير اييي المناطق اللوجسيه يمكن
والمناطق الفريزون اول ما تيجي هذه انا
اعتقد القطاع الخاص ما عاد حجه يمكن انا
لو لو دور الحكومي بس شوي احنا طبعا في
سواء في غرفه الرياض او في اللجنه الوطنيه
اللوجستيه احنا نقول ما هو بدورنا فقط انه
نحاول نستفيد من الفراس ونمثل القطاع
ونزيل التحديات لكن لا بد نطور انفسنا حنا
كشركات لوجستيه كقطاع لوجستي
عشان يتواكب مع الحكومه الحكومه اليوم
يعني ما شاء الله عليها صارت اسرع من
القطاع اللوجستي ولا احنا قادرين نواكبه
فلا بد انك قطع خاصه وفعلا نشتغل على
انفسنا ونطور من انفسنا عشان انه نراقب
التطور الكبير
اعود على انه كيف سهوله الاعمال والاسعار
رخيصه تجذب المستثمرين سواء محليين او
دوليين
احنا قبلنا مدن اظن في اربيل 2015
اغلى شوي بس نمشيها لهم يعني 18 ريال
المتر التصاريح البلديه الدفاع المدني
كلها عن طريق يعني ما يحتاج انك تروح
وتصير همم المشاكل
فسهلوا لنا العمل تماما فشف كيف سهوله
العمل يدعوك انك تستمر هنا في الدمام
الثانيه تكلفنا يمكن حوالي 15 مليون ما
زال الرقم صغير ولا كبير ما زال استثمار
جاء فتخيل انك الموت هذا انك تكرره على
الاكبر تتطلب انك تعطي اراضي اكبر باسعار
مره اخرى منطقيه بعدها بتجيك الشركه سواء
السعوديه احنا بدانا 2016 والحمد لله
مبسوطين الان بنوقع مع الجبين عنده منطقه
همم لوجسيه ان شاء الله على امل على وجهك
بعدها بيكون في توسع ان شاء الله في همم
في الرياض وفي جده بحول الله الله يبارك
لكم
الراسمال البشري انا خليني اختم هالحوار
الممتع بموضوع ما له دخل بقطع لوجستيب حكم
عليه يعني هو يخص كل قطاعات اقتصاديه
موضوع انت مهتم فيه ومن زمان تكتب عنا ولك
اطروحه يعني تستحق ان نعرضها خصوصا انه في
حلقات سابقه عرضنا اكثر من الاطروحه تخص
مشكله البطاله همم والتعامل معه انا بكتب
بس من احد مقالاتك اللي كتبتها 316 عن
السعوده ههه
قبل 15 سنه
المحاوله ثم سعود الذهب وفشلت المحاوله ثم
سعوده سوق الخضار وفشلت المحاوله ثم قيل
لنا ان المشكله في ان الرواتب قليله فرتب
فارتفع راتب موظف موظف في المطعم موظف
مطعم السعودي من 2000 الى 6000 الاف اي
بالنسبه ل 300% وفشلنا فيها ايضا ثم قيل
لنا سنقلل من ساعات العمل وستشهد المحاوله
ثم قيل لنا سنرفع تكلفه العامل الاجنبي
ليكون السعودي مرغوبه وايضا فشلنا ثم
وقفنا الاستقدام البلد ثم فرضنا ليس بسعر
قطاع الخاص فزادت السعوديه الوهميه ودفعت
الحكومه نصف راتب الموظف السعودي ومع هذه
السعوديه همم كانت هي سيده الوقوف وقدمت
الحكومه مكافات ماليه للشاب السعودي الذي
يكمل عملا في شركه لمده عام وايضا لم ينجح
واذا دفعت الحكومه تكلفه التدريب الشباب
فاصبحت بعد مراكز التدريب تتقاسم الدعم مع
المتدرب وهو نائم في
كل هذه الحلول لم تنجح وين المشكله
اول شيء الله يسامحك
[ضحك]
طيب انا انا بعطيك وجهه نظره بحاول اني
انا احس اني محايد
لسبب انه يعني انا جالسه اشوف الصوره من
من خارج المملكه ومن داخلها دي تجربه
محليه واللي تجربه علميه مشكله البطاله
مشكله مهمه وحلها ما هم للجميع ما هم
للمجتمع الاقتصاد لانك قطع خاصه ايضا
العاطلين عن العمل وهم الاهم بما انهم
مقبولين على همم يعني حياتهم
في وجهه نظري انه وزاره العمل عمل جبار
رغم ها المقال وانا من 2011 انتقدهم واي
قرار يطلعونا ويقول بيفشن ولكن انا اعتقد
انه وزاره العمل عملت جبار خلال اكثر من
20 سنه لا من ناحيه برامج التدريب ولا
التطبيق ولا سياسات العمل ولا الخدمات
الالكترونيه ولا اعتقد انه في وزاره او
حكومه في العالم عملت للبطاله مثل اللي
عملته وزاره العمل السعوديه
لحل مشكله البطاله ونجح ونجاح كبير بصراحه
يذكر يعني يذكر فيه يشكر في الخدمات
التقنيه وخدمه العميل همم هذه كانوا من
السباقين في الوزارات همم فيها
اذا تتذكر يعني
كنا نرسل المعقب بعد صلاه الفجر عشان ياخذ
رقم الساعه 11:00 يجي الدور 11 وثلاث
دقائق يقول لهم الموظف اوراق ناس تعال
بكره اسبوع عشان تخلص معامله واحده اليوم
في ثلاث دقائق ونت واقف عند اشاره تخلص
معاملاتك ايضا نجحوا في شيء مهم جدا اللي
هو زاد واعداد السعوديين في القطاع الخاص
ورواتهم الى ارقام قياسيه مقارنه بالسنوات
الماضيه هذه فعلا نجاحات كبيره وفي نجاحات
اخرى
ولكن عمر السؤال الاهم هل نجحت وزاره
العمل رغم بذل او ما انفق من اموال ورغم
ما بذل من جهود في حل مشكله البطاله اليوم
بناء على همم رايه وزاره العمل والاو
ارقامهم وارقام الاحصاء الوزاره لم تنجح
ما زالت البطاله 12% طبعا الى 2018 وبدات
تنزل الان الحمد لله
تقعد تنزل الان طيب خليني بقول لك السؤال
الاهم قبل النزول هذا السؤال الاهم
وين الخلل 20 سنه صرفت مليارات وما انحلت
البطاله وين الخلف هل احنا ماشين في
الطريق الصحيح ولا لا طيب هل في تجارب
عالميه فعلا حلت البطاله وفي كم لان نتكلم
عن سنغافوره وماليزي قبل 20 30 سنه خلنا
نتكلم عن وقت في تجربه للالمانيه تجربه
جميله وشبيه فيها نفس الروح نجحت المانيا
2002 2003 2004 كانت المانيا من اسود اسوا
دول اوروبا في البطاله كانت البطاله
المعلنه طبعا في تقارير تقول 14% وتقارير
11% والسبب انه كانت تتراوح ما بين 9% الى
16% على حسب في الجهه الشرقيه او الجهه
الغربيه من المانيا
وكان النمو الاقتصادي سيء جدا اسوء شيء في
اوروبا كان واحد فاصله سته
اللي صار انه ال ال المانيا حلتها في ثمان
سنوات
في 2012 اظن او 13 اصبحت بطالتهم 4%
فعندنا مثال جيد
انا طبعا ضد انك تروح تاخذ
المثال هذا والطبق في السعوديه لكن البطل
مختلفه في كل البلد المختلفه لكن احنا
نقول الان السؤال نرجع لسؤالنا ليش 20 سنه
ما قدرنا نحل البطاله رغم المجهود الكبير
اللي موجود السؤال هذا انا اعتقد انه همم
جواب لا يقدر بثمن وجهه نظري انا اللي
دائما اختلف انا همم وجهه نظر رسمي خلينا
نقول متبلنه وزاره العمل وكثير من
الاقتصاديين
الوزاره العمل
وقعت في خطاين استراتيجيه من 20 سنه
واستمرت فيها الخطائين الى الى قبل كم سنه
انا بعد 2018 ما تابعتهم ولكن
ايضا ممكن نتكلم فيها الخطا الاستراتيجي
الاول انه تشخيص البطاله او اسباب البطاله
قبل 20 سنه لم يكن دقيق كان بالنسبه 80%
غير دقيقه و20% يمكن صحيح
فبالتالي اي قرارات تبنى عليه
تكون نتائجها 20% تنجح و80% تفشل لكنها ال
20% النجاح ما يكفي انه انه يحل مشكله
البطاله
طيب ال ال
ايش اللي يصير في على مدار 20 سنه كل
اداره جديده تجي لوزاره العمل تخلي تعتبر
التشخيص هذا هو قران منزل ولا تلمسه ايش
تسوي تغير في القرارات
ك غلط مخرجات كلاود انها تكون غلط
فبالتالي اصبحت القرارات يعد تدويرها يعني
سمعنا عن من 20 سنه سعوده القطاع الفلاني
سعوده ليموزين سعوده سوق الخضار فاستمرت
لانه انت التشخيص محدود ولا هو صحيح فقررت
قاعد تدويره وزاره العمل
تشخيص وزاره العمل البطاله انت سمعته يعني
من اكثر من واحد هم يقول لك
العماله هم سبب المشكله العماله الرخيصه
هي سبب المشكله همم عندنا سوق عمل همم
عشوائي او زي ما يذكرونه همم مخرجات
التعليم وغيرها التشخيص هذا بحداته همم
خليه يقول لك الخطا الاستراتيجي الثاني
خطا الاستراتيجي الثاني انه في الخطا
الاصوات الاول هو التشخيص الخاطئ الخاطئ
وتعاقب الادارات اللي يركز على التنفيذ
وليس على مراجعه التشخيص صحيح وش خطا
استراتيجي الثاني خطا الاستراتيجي الثاني
انه حل البطاله او كلاه الحكومه الى وزاره
العمل وهو من واجبها الاصيل ومن حقها
الاصيل انها تحل الوظائف اللي صار انه
وزاره العمل اخذت الواجب هذا وحولته على
القطاع الخاص وقالت انت يا قطاع خاص مسؤول
عن البطاله تحلها وابداع في تحفيزه
ومراقبته ومعاقبته
القطاع الخاص
ما هو من واجبات ولا هو من طبيعه يقدر يحل
مشاكل بطاله هو القطاع الخاص انت تخلق له
بيئه عمل سهله بحيث انه يكبر وينمو ويخلق
لك وظائف
وبالتالي يساهم في حل البطاله لكن ما تقدر
تقول لحل مشكله البطاله ايش اللي صار على
مدى 20 سنه وانت لاحظتها لحظه يعني قاعد
يحاول القطاع الخاص يحلها ما قدر فبديه
يتملص مسؤولياته وزاره العمل كل ما بدا
يتملص من المسؤوليه تشد عليه بالرقابه
ولكن مثل على قوله الوالدين ملزق يطيح الى
اليوم القطاع الخاص يصيح والجماعه او
وزاره العمل
يعني
عمران في حلقه سابقه معنا ومحمد جابر في
حلقه سابقه معنا بعد كل اللي انت ذكرتها
يقولون المشكله القطاع الخاص ادمن هذا
العمل الرخيصه والمعالجه هي خلاص
لقطاع الليموزين تمسك لقطاع خلاص سوي
توطين 100% وبالتالي همم انت تتجنب
الاخذ والعطاء اللي بالك من القطاع الخاص
شوف اذا الكلام هذا يعني اذا بتاخذ بالطب
قفل سيفشل من اول انا على فكره اتفق معهم
في امور كثيره خلافي معهم على التشخيص
وليس على الحلو فانا ما عندي خلاف مع
حلولهم جميله وكل شيء ولكنها لا يمكن ان
تتطبق بمعنى هم يقول لك الاقتصاد العماله
الرخيصه فتح لها الباب على الغرب صحيح
العماله الرخيصه كان في حاجه البلد تمر
بتنميه كبيره جدا العماله الرخيصه هذه
بنات لك تقريبا حوالي 30,000 مدرسه 40
مطار دوري محليات مستشفيات اللي هي اليوم
انت رقم واحد في ترابط الطرق من شمال
المملكه اللي شرقهم الى جنومهم الى غربها
ثمانيه اشياء من اللي بناها بناها
السعوديه بفلوسهم باشرافهم لكن نحتاجه
عماله همم انها هل الرخيص هذا شيء سلبي
يعني اروح ادفع 20 مليار بدل 10 مليار
عشان تكون عماله غاليه او الحل للبديل اني
اوقف ولا ابني طرق
ايش اللي كان امام المملكه كان امامنا
فعلا تجيب عماله 90 فيهم ايش اللي صار نثج
عن هذا تشوهات
ولكن هذا مو مشوه هذا خدم لك البلد خدم لك
التعليم خدم لك الاقتصاد وصل عندك اليوم
حجمه اقتصاد 2,000,000 تريليون لا والله
ثم البنيه التحتيه هذه اللي ساهمت انت
والعماله الاجنبيه في بناها كان ما وصل
الاقتصاد هذا الحجر لكن شو اللي صار في
ثغرات من ناحيه شراء الفيز وبعلف واصبح
هناك مشكله
يطلع له عشره في 20 فيزه ويروح يخليهم
يروحون في البلد ويروحون هذه هي التشوهات
فانت اذا اذا تبي تحل لابد انك تحل يعني
وش الشيء اللي مفقود لاشوف اللي موجود
صحيح
الحالي همم
لابد انه نرجع ونشخص مشكله البطاله
[موسيقى]
الوزاره اليوم اخطر شيء اخطر شيء
انك تسالوش الحلول اليوم اليوم المملكه او
وزاره العمل بحاجه الى تشخيص صحيح للبطاله
الاطباء ايش يقولون الاطباء يقول لك
التشخيص الصحيح هو نصف العلاج انا بقول لك
بطالتنا في السعوديه التشخيص الصحيح لها
هو 90% من العلاج لان نملك القدرات
البشريه والماليه ان نحن البطاره احنا لو
سوينا مثل المانيا ولا نسوي كوبي ولكن مثل
تجربه المانيا في حل المشكله وفي وفي همم
عمل تشخيص صحيح للبطاله كان ممكن بطالتنا
اليوم 4% بل مو باليوم كان المفروض في
2015 فصالاتنا اربعين همم
طيب وبقول لك المانيا نرجع على موضوع
اهميه التشخيص انا اقول اليوم التشخيص
واهم شيء وليس الحلول بعد ما تخلص الحلول
سابقه للامانه اليوم تشخص بالطريقه
الصحيحه وبعدين اعطني الحلو يعني وصف لي
المرض وبعدين اعطوني العلاج ايش سوت
المانيا مثل ما قلت لك انه كانت البطاله
تقريبا 14%
كانت الشركات تعاني في المانيا
تقول انا ما القى موظفين طيب في بطاله 14
% وظفيهم تقول لك لا ما يبغى يتوضا مسجل
في البطاله
الالمانيه الشركات الالمانيه بدات تقفل
لانها لا تستطيع تستخدم عماله وهذا يمكن
على رد همم مثل ما ذكرت انه ايش العمل
الرخيصه لا تستطيع انها تستخدم عماله ولا
تستطيع توظف من السوق المحلي ايش تسوي
انها تطلع فاصبحت تطلع برا المانيا عشان
تشتغل جابوا موظف حكومي ايام شرودر جاب
موظف حكومي عشان يحل مشكله البطاقه
دخل في جدال وهواش زي الجدال اللي داير
لذلك انا مابي ادخل في جدار هو اهم شيء
التشخيص فدخل في جدال مع منظمات العمل
اللي عندهم او اليوم نقابات العماليه مع
الموظفين يا جماعه تعالوا اشتغلوا يا
جماعه الوضع ما قدر يحل مشكله البطاله
لانه المشكله التقليديه او المشكله الغير
تقليديه لابد حل غير تقليدي لها مشكله
البطاله عندنا وعند غيرنا غير التقليديه
بس تعال شرودر همم
اتش ار دايركتر او او بشريه الموارد
البشريه في بوكس واجب اسمه بيتر هارت فاست
عام فيه حل مشكله البطاله
سوي نفس اللي انا قاعده طالب فيه الان
التشخيص طبعا هي ما نشرتك كيف استدي
ودراسه في 2014 2015
انه جاء قال يا جماعه جلست انا اظن او
سنتين يدرس ما هي الاسباب الحقيقيه
للبطاله يعني جلس سنه وسنتين في التشخيص
لتشخيص البطاله ما جاءوا اعطى حلول
برامج دعم ما اجي قالت قال اعطونا ما هي
الاسباب او التشخيص الصحيح لها تخيلوا
اشكال التشخيص
اكتشفوا انه نظام التامينات الاجتماعيه
عندهم في المانيا كريم جدا
بمعنى انت اليوم فصلت من عملك او استقلت
وراتبك خلينا نقول 5,000 يورو يستمر راتب
5,000 رول لمده سنه او سنتين اعتقد فانت
وش تدافع عندك انك ترجع للوظيفه
وانت مجبر انك تسجل في البطاله عشان
تستلموا ال 5000
فاصبحوا الالمان او جزء من الالمان جالس
في بيته بخمسه الاف يورو ما يبغى يشتغل
مبسوط متكفي تيجي الشركات تقول بعطيك 5000
يورو يقول لا يا اخي انا جالس في البيت و
5 الاف يو طيب بعطيك 6000 يورو قل لها ما
تسوى المشوار فاكتشف انه عندهم خلل وعندهم
سبب البطاله انا ما اقول هذا هو نفس السبب
اللي عندنا لذلك بطالتنا احنا مختلفه
تشخيصها مختلفه لكن لازم نعرف السبب اللي
نتجت عند همم نسجت من البطاله في السعوديه
عشان نحلها هو اكتشف السبب ووضع حلول لحل
المشكله هذه حل المشكله طبعا حلول ما همم
موجوده في في النت وضع حلو نحلت المشكله
يعني في تقريبا حوالي ثمان سنوات نزلت
المانيا
من بطاله 14% الى 3.5%
رغم الازمه الماليه اللي صارت في 2008
يعني شوي تاخروا شوي وبعدين ينزله الى
ثلاثه اللي انا اقصده اليوم التشخيص
الصحيح هو النص الحل انا اقول لابد انه
ركز اليوم ولا نتناقش ولا نتجادل في موضوع
الحلول فلان يقول يعني هذه الحلول الصحيحه
انا اقول اليوم يعني اعطيتك مثالي يمكن
اشبه احنا كلنا كاننا رايحين الحمله تحج
وركبنا وسواق الباص ودانا همم مسكنا طريق
الدمام الجماعه الاخوان يقولون خلونا نركب
سيارات اصغر اسرع او نروح بالطياره وانا
قاعد اقول يا جماعه حلول صحيحه هذه
بتوصلنا اسرع لكن الطريق غير صحيح الطريق
اللي احنا ماشيين فيه غير صحيح لا بد نرجع
نشوف وين ال- ال- الوجه حقتنا ونعدي الخطر
الاستراتيجي
فيه يمكن اخر ثلاث سنوات استفدت شيء صراحه
من من العمل مع الجهات الحكوميه والقطاع
الخاص
لا تنشغل عمر او اذا اشغلت نفسك بالمهم عن
الاهم ضيعت الاثنين ركز في البدايه على
الاشياء الاستراتيجيه انا سهل اني اذا
بروح للحج باص اقول انه يعني بطيء وبركب
سياره او باخذ تكسي اسرع لي لكن صعب اذا
انا وجهتي للدمام سواء ركبت بس باص ولا
طياره لن اصل الى لانه انا ماسك الطريق
الخطا فالاخطاء الاستراتيجيه لا تغتر
لا حط كثير من الاجتماع
التشغيليه عن الامور الاستراتيجيه
فبالتالي الامور استراتيجيه هي الطريق
الصحيح الامور التشغيليه هذه تحصيل حاصل
سر وصولك تهون وصولك تخدمك في الوصول
ولكنها هي لوحدها ما تكفي للوصول الى هدف
فينك ما قاله عبد الله في جريده الجزيره
2012 احنا كلنا رجعنا ههه
طرح اقوى تقول انت الحل للقضاء على
البطاله يبدا من البيت اذا لم يشد الاهل
على يدي ابنائهم باكمال الدراسه او
الالتحاق بالمعاهد الفنيه وتربيتهم على
تحمل المسؤوليه فان الفشل سيلازم الابناء
وبالتالي ستزيد البطاله واذا لم يستطع
عليها الفعل ذلك اتمنى ان تقوم الدوله
بذلك بالاخذ على ايدها الشريحه للشباب
ومساعدتهم اما بجعل التعليم اجباريا او
بتجنيدهم اجباريا اما تركهم ما بين جلسه
في البيت بدون عمل او التجمر في الشوارع
والموقعها والتفحيط ومضايقه المجتمع فهذا
يضرهم ولا يضر المجتمع فانت قاعد تنظر
البطاله مشكله اجتماعيه بينما اتذكر مثلا
دائما يحاول البس قبعه الطرف المضادات
عشان الاسئله النقاش اتذكر محمد جابر يقول
البطانه مو مشكله اجتماعيه البطاله مشكله
اقتصادي بحته في مجتمع واقتصاد يحضر فيه
الشعب السعودي بالمنافسه غير عادله معلش
اخص اخر مستعد اطول
ويرضى باجواء وبيئه عمل همم اقل بكثير همم
هل الحل اللي انت تراه يبدا من البيت طيب
يعني في ثلاث نقاط يمكن هي الانتاجيه
والبطاله طبعا هذه المقالات القديمه
الصراحه اذا شفت التغريدات القديمه
والمقالات القديمه يعني حماسيه يمكن
تراجعت شيء بسيطه عن انا اللي ذكرته ترى
قبل عشر سنوات انا اعتقد العاطل عن العمل
سواء
برغبته يعني بطاله اختياريه او بدون رغبته
هو
ناتج المجتمع
والنظام الحكومي او النظام التعليمي فاا
من الخطا ان نحمله مشكله البطاله فلذلك
انا اقول
البطاله هي معادله من ثلاث عناصر القطاع
الخاص همم والاقتصاد عموما همم الحكومه
ومنظماته تشريعاتها اللي يتمثلها وزاره
العمل والمجتمع
انت متى ما انشات يعني انسان
جاد وقادر على العمل
بالراحه انه يعمل في اي وظيفه ليش اليوم
وهنا نرجع لموضوع الانتاجيه هم طبعا في
رايه وزاره العمل او راي الشباب بيقول لك
انه ارفع تكلفه العامل الاجنبي هذا من
2014 وعرضتها بشده يقول لك ارفع راتب
العامل الاجنبي بحيث يكون السعودي مرغوب
مازلنا نقول هذا حل غير مستتر السعودي يجب
انه يكون مرغوب حتى لو رفع راتبه السعوديه
يجب ان يكون
الانتاجيه هي معيار التوظيف وهي ليس
الجنسيه الجنسيه ال ال ال الانتاجيه هي
معيار التوظيف وهي معيار المفاضله وهي
معيار المناصب وهي معيار الترقيات حتى
احنا كيف نفرق ما بين
لذلك معلش لابد انه نعمل على رفع انتاجيه
الفرد السعودي همم
بجميع فئاته احنا الانتاجيه يعني شيء مهم
احنا اهملناه لانه كان عندنا نفطر الحمد
لله
فما كنا مركزين عليه لكن ايش الفرق ما بين
الدول الغنيه والدول الفقيره اللي ما
عندها همم حتى الغنيه اللي ما عندها بتروح
هي الانتاجيه وايش الفرق ما بين الشخص
الغني والشخص الفقير هو الانتاجيه
الانتاجيه تكون نوعيتها ايش اللي يفرق ما
بين
شاب سعودي عمره 18 سنه الشركات هافت عليه
براتب 15 او 18000
وما بين شاب سعودي
راتبه مثلا 5000
ويجيء الصعوبه في ايجاد وظيفه ثانيه هو
نوع الانتاجيه وكميتها انتاجيه تحكم
بالنوع بالكيف هذا اي تي مطلوب وهذا شخص
خلنا نقول ممكن انه كاشير في مطعم يمكن
استبداله
فكلهم يجدون وظائف اذا هم همم يعني همم
جادين في العمل ويبحثون العمل وظائف فانا
اعتقد انه اليوم احنا في سوق هنا في
السماء داخل المملكه او خارج المملكه لا
بد ان نعمل على تطوير الانسان بحيث انه
الانسان يكون منتج للانسان المنتج يعني
مثل الغيمه الممطره اي مكان تحطه فيه يمطر
اي قطاع تحطه فيهم فلذلك انا اقول انه
البطاله احنا بنتكلم عن الحدود يعني
الحلول وانا ضد اني اتكلم عن الحلول
انا اعتقد انه لا قلت ان نركز على التشخيص
ولكن
البطاله انا اعتقد انه جزء من حلولها هو
تعليمي مجتمعي اقتصادي اا
كلنا نلعب دور فيه ثواني احنا بقى او
مجتمع او او ريادي اعمال او حكومه وقطاع
خاص لابد انه يعني نتعاون على اساس انه
نحل مشكله البطاله تعاون طرفين منها
المعادله احنا قلنا ثلاثه اطراف المعادله
ترى فهم بدون الطرف الثالث لن ننجح في حل
البطاقه ان تستطيع ان تنشا مدارس لكن لا
تستطيع ان تجبر الناس على التعليم تستطيع
انك تخلق وظائف ولكن لا تستطيع ان تجبر
الناس على العمل فيها
والالتزام بها في عينه بسيطه من الشباب قد
يكونون اثروا على سمعه الشاب السعودي بانه
غير ملتزمين ونسمع دائما في قطاع الاعمال
همم هذه لابد انه ثغره هذه اذا فعلا ظاهره
انه لابد انه نعمه لحلها لكن نروح نجيء
نترك عن الحلول على جنب من وقت الحلول
الحلول سابق لاوانها انا اقول اذا مسؤول
عن البطاله اول دوامه في وزاره العمل قال
يا فريق العمل اعطوني حلول معناها لن تحل
مشكله البطاله نقطه ثانيه
البطاله عندنا غير التقليديه وتحتاج حل
غير تقليدي
النقطه يمكن
الاخيره في في
موضوع البطاله انا اعتقد انه انه لابد انه
اول شيء مثل ما قلنا نرجع للتشخيص الصحيح
متى هي هي نقطه الانطلاقه هي بدايه السباق
احنا اليوم بدون تشخيص صحيح كان واحد قاعد
يصيد في الظلام
بتيجي في راس خويه ولا بضيع رصاصك عشان
اقفل بس المحور واختمها الحوار بسؤال بس
قبل مشهد واحد لانه طلع كثيره
[موسيقى]
اليوم من الماخذ مثلا اللي يطحها فريق
محمد الجابر وغيرهم على شكل الاقتصاد سوق
العمل اليوم بيننا انت اليوم عندك مستودع
مدام متاح لك تجيب اربعه اسيويين همم
براتب جدا زهيده همم ويشيلوا لك يحملوا لك
البضائع
عمرك ما تستثمر في ماكينه مكيفه همم
ما يجيء واحد سعودي بدل هاربعه ويقوم بهذا
المهمه فطالما هذه الاربعه متاحين لن
تستثمر في المكينه لن تستثمر في تدريب هذا
السعودي على استخدامها بينما اذا غيبت هذا
الخيار همم ستطر الى الاستثمار في
الماكينه وفي استقطاب السعودي والتدريب
وتوفير بيئه العمل المريح له حتى انه يقوم
بها المهمه مثل هذا المشهد وشلون تعلق
عليه
بمساله الحلول والتشخيص اللي ما تروح طيب
انا اتفق معهم تماما على انه اول شيء
عندنا عندنا عماله فائضه عن الحاجه وفعلا
رفع كفاءه القطاعات كلها انه بيقلل من
العماله واعطيت المثال انت اليوم الف شركه
لوجسيه بخلي نقول بعشره الاف عامل قد تخدم
همم 50,000 او 100,000 مصنع يوظف لي
200,000 عام مخصص بس للقطع فهذي اول طريقه
انك تقلل من عدد العماله ولكن كمان تلغيها
تماما لانك انت مازلت تحتاج همم انت اليوم
عندك 6 مليون او 7 مليون عمل اجنبي بينما
همم اللي يطلبون العمل او العاطلين عن
العمل 800,000 اعتقد انه 600,700,000 نساء
ويمكن 200,000 رجال العدد هذا لا يكفي
لمشاريع تنميه البلد بمعنى
اذا اذا مشينا على الراي اللي يقول ما
نحتاج عماله اجنبيه طيب وقفنا العماله
اجنبي سهله وقفها وحاولوا على فكره قرارين
يعني ايام الدكتور غازي القصيبي الله
يرحمه ايام المهندس عادل الفقيه ان شلت
البلد اذا انت بتوقفهم انت ما عندك اعداد
كافيه مدربه من السعوديه او غير مدربه
اعداد كافيه من السعوديين انها تشغل ال ال
الوظائف هذه معناها كيف بتسوي نيو
كيف بتسوي القديه كيف بتسوي السكه الحديد
اللي بتربط طيب انت عندك سته مليون الان
الواضح فلابد نسالها انفسنا اول شيء هل
نحتاج عماله ولا ما نحتاج عماله
بموجب الارقام هذه مليون سعودي وسته مليون
عام اجنبي
انت اليوم لو راحت العماله انشل البلد
تماما يعني المطارات النظافه وغيرها
فنحتاج عماله لغايه ما يكون عندنا كوادر
بشريه بما يكفي العدد اللي يكفي انها تغطي
الوظائف هذه سواء احنا ما نتكلم عن جدول
الان هذه الوظائف مرغوبه او غير مرغوبه
انا اقول ان شاء الله يعني في بعض الاراء
يقول لك خلي السعودي مثلا توضح عامل
النظافه واللي يصير فني انا اقول ان شاء
الله احنا اقتصاد قوي وعندنا فرص كبيره
للشباب السعودي ما يحتاج انه يدخل في هذا
الوظائف والعماله ما هي عيب موجوده في
جميع البلدان اما عن طريق الاستقدام او عن
طريق التجنيس فهي فينا ولا تنمو الدول الا
عن طريق الاستفاده من من بعضها معاملات
بعضها انه على اساس ان تسوي ال ال
المشاريع التقنيه فالاجابه نعتقد السؤال
اللي لازم يوجه للشباب هل احنا محتاجين
العماله ولا لا نعم محتاجين السؤال ما هو
القدر اللي نحتاجه الان بحيث ما يضر
العاطلين عن العمل وهنا ندخل في تشعب سؤال
ثاني ما هي الوظائف اللي ممكن انه نساعدها
بحيث انها ودخلها عالي بحيث ان سعود فيها
السعوديين وبعدها نجي للعماله المتبقيه
هذه لكن الى عشر سنوات قدام مستحيل انك
همم
تستغني عن العماله ابي اعطي بس باذكر
المشكله الناس انا انا اتمنيت انا عندي
ورقه عمل رصدت فيها قرارات وزاره العمل
والنتائج اللي صار عليها في 2014 كان في
قرار حاسم على تخيل ايقاف العماله
المخالفه المخالفه ما نتكلم عن
اتذكر انا كم مكتبه في طريق الملك فهد
اليوم هذاك طريق الملك فهد فاضي اللي اللي
صار الهادي المشاريع كلها توقفت ما كمل
القرار اسبوع ورجع وانت تتكلم عن
المخالفين فقط
مشكله الاعمال المخالفه مشكله هذه هنا
بعدين يجي لها حلو ولكن شوف المخالفه طيب
جينا في قرار ثاني قلنا وقف الفيس يا اخي
وقف الفيس القطاع الخاص هذا مدمن اعماله
رخيصه وقف الفيس وقفنا في الفيس اصبح
القطاع الخاص ياخذ من بعضها الاجانب اللي
راتبه 20 ارتفعت رواتب المهندسين الذكر
واثنا عشر 13 من 8000 ريال الاجنبي لها
حوالي 25,000 ريال
طبعا حتى رواتب السعوديين الله حق ارتفعت
بحوالي اييي ضعف هذا ولكن لانه في طلب في
طلب في السوق فبالتالي ارتفعت بعد فتره
فتحت الفيس والتاشيرات فاحنا نقول اليوم
احنا في بلد في خير الحمد لله ولا ولا
يمنع بقليل من الرفاهيه انها استخدم
اذا انها ما تضر
اقتصادك يعني احد الاخوان ذكر جمع اشوف
الجمع دخل العماله الاجنبيه في في مثلا
يمكن 20 سنه
اليوم يا اخي ما هي القيمه اللي نسجت من
من اعمالهم على البلد اقتصاديا انت وصلت
الى اقتصاد 2 اليوم وصلت الى مثل ما قلنا
شبكه طرق انت الاول في العالم عندك مئات
الالاف وملائم البشر يعملون في المدارس
هذه في المطارات في غيره فهم مو بس انه
بنوا لك البنيه التحتيه ولكن حتى خلقه لك
وظائف كان في دراسه تقول لابد انه من 16
عامل اجنبي
همم
وقف اليوم يعني انت انا دائما اقول سوي لك
ستريم اذا جاءك حل سوي لك ستريم طيب خلينا
نسوي سيناريو اليوم انا وياك مشهد سريع
وقفنا العماله اليوم او بكره او بعد سنه
وش بصير في البلد عندك مدينه الرياض كانت
خمسه كيلو في خمسه كيلو اليوم 40 كيلو في
40 كيلو من ينظفها من يصونها من يشغلها ست
الصباح لما تمشي وعامل معلق فوق لمبه قاعد
يصلح لك اللمبات عشان تمر في الليل
والطريق مضاعف
هذه نعمه كيف توصل
شغلك البنيه التحتيه اليوم الرقميه انت
انت من الاوائل في العالم
فقيمه انا اعتقد انه اذا المفروض انه يكون
في دراسه كم القيمه اللي خلقتها العماله
الاجنبيه هذه الاقتصاد عشان نكون عادلين
ولا نظرهم ولا نظرهم انفسهم في الاخير خير
البلد اهل البلد الاولويه للسعودي ولكن لا
بد انك تعملها بذكاء يعني همم احد همم انا
دائما استفيد من كبار السن يعني واحده من
النساء الله يغفر الله يرحمها
تقولي اذا خسرت تربح لا تخسر وتخسروا وين
امك اذا خسرت فربح حرمه حيه يعني انت دفعت
فلوس على الاقل يكون في مردود من وراه انت
خسرت في الامانه صح الدفاعات حقهم واعرقهم
ولكن شوف كم روحت منهم مطار مثل المطار
الرياض تخيل انه مو موجود مو انا اليوم
تستقبل عشره مليون حاويه تخيل انه مو
موجود تيجي تقول السعوديينونها
يعني السعوديين في الوظائف الحكوميه المهم
يعني وصلنا وقت انه الحكومه توظف اجانب
لانه ما كان فيه عدد كافي انا لو من
الوزاره العمل صراحه اوقف كل اللي قاعد
اشتغل فيه من ناحيه البطاله وارجع اكلف
الفريق كامل
باعاده تشخيص البطاله بشكل الصحيح وبعدها
وضع الحلو انا بختم ابو عبد الله بسؤال
يهمني
اسمع منك الاجابه بحكم تجربتك اثريه اليوم
بعدها الرحله اللي ما شاء الله تمتد حدود
20 سنه او اكثر في مجال الاعمال وش
النصيحه او او التوصيه اللي تقدمها لشاب
في بدايه الرحله وقاعد يشوف نوع عمال
الامور يعني تغيرته الطيور طاطات وارزاقها
حقين عقار اغتنوا حقي التطبيقات اغتنوا
وهو جاي اللي مشهد يحس انه مكتمل وبعد له
مكان فيه فهوش تقول لهم والله شف همم انا
هذا اللي همم يعني عبد الله الله متخرج من
الثانوي بنفس النصيحه اللي صح يا عبد الله
همم البلد فيه خير الحمد لله
واجبنا تجاه الخير انه حافظ عليه نرميه
ونستفيد منه مقدار استفاداتنا منه بمقدار
جهدنا لنبذ العالم انفسنا
وحرصنا على تطوير انفسنا وللتزام بالعمل
لما تخرجنا من الجامعه ذكر الاعلام كان
اتذكر الرقم كان كاتب انه 140 او 145
دكتور في الهندسه عاطل عن العمل ومقدم على
جامعه الملك سعود يعطيك ايحاء انه البطاله
مخيفه
انه اذا دكتور ما توظف وايش بصير كانوا
يقولوا لنا انه اللي ما لحق على طفره
الثمانينات لن يقتني كانوا يقولوا لنا اذا
ما شريت ارض في العليا بريال مثل فلان
وفلان لن تغتني اليوم ادخل نقول ما ابغى
اقول كم الرقم السنوات لكن اليوم منا من
جيلنا فيهم التجار فيهم اللي في وظائف في
منهم الرؤساء الشركات همم فالكلام اللي
اللي قال هذا يعني ما كان صحيح الاهم
صراحه انه الواحد يركز انه انه يبني نفسه
بحيث انه يستفيد من من الخير اللي همم في
البلد الله يقويكم عبد الله شكرا على قبول
الدعوه وبالتوفيق في
مساهمتكم مع الجهات حكوميه في بناء مركز
لوجستي عالمي داخل السعوديه الله يسعدك
شكرا
لكم شكرا لك هذا القصير في اعداد وانتاجها
الحلقه ياسر الغانم ونواف العنزه خلف
الكاميرات في تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المجنزي وفي التحرير انس الخليل وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف
على الانتاج صالح با سلامه
احد المنتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]